when you're making the show that is
about a culture that maybe the majority
of the people that are watching the show
or can potentially watch a show are not
familiar with how do you make sure it
satisfies the people of the culture and
represents them but also is appealing to
people who are unaware of it that's
something when I was watching the first
episode I was like God this is like
really fun it was maybe maybe I'm
curious and I like these things but it
was like really fun to learn the little
nuances yeah yeah the culture but do you
think about that yeah we think about all
the time I mean we you know and this is
something that has been exciting about
getting to make
um most Show on Netflix with him too is
that it's a totally different tone and
it highlights different things so
there's a lack and so we never really
create from a lack so if I'm making
something and I'm saying well there's
nothing so it has to be everything I
think it will probably be pretty bad
yeah so I kind of make something knowing
there will be a lot of people who don't
like that it doesn't have this thing or
that thing or don't like what I'm
focused on you know focusing on or
whatever but but the parts that do work
I wanted them to at least work for me or
like to work for people who I know will
find it fun so it being its own thing
um but yeah we don't think about too
much of you know
um where people might be upset or
anything want to be sensitive but if you
make it from them you know comedy it's
not fun when you're just thinking about
the reaction yes yeah uh there's a show
called RuPaul's Drag Race yeah you're
familiar with that I've heard of it
incredibly popular show yeah and I was
speaking to you know Mateo yeah of
course yeah and he said well the reason
why this uh the reason but one of the
reasons why the show is so popular in
the gay community is because it didn't
feel like a gay show that was made for
straight people yeah and I watched her
show and I didn't feel like it was made
for me yeah like there are things I
didn't understand yeah and I was really
cool because I'm curious and I'm like oh
I didn't know these things but it didn't
feel as like this is how Egyptian
Muslims are white people right right is
that the secret well that's also what
what Akash was saying too about like
um the why it's hard to watch sometimes
when it's like real dude yeah because
you're like oh wait this is kind of like
me and that's why it's hard to watch
because I actually think it is for us
and so sometimes people will be like oh
you're making this show for America and
you're whitewashing it or whatever I'll
have people say that and I always find
that odd because yeah it's an American
show but it's so specific to our
community it's like like so much of what
we're getting and I also think they
don't understand what it's it's not like
it's a struggle but it is different
being American Egyptian yeah American
and and Indian because there's an
episode and season one where you go back
to Egypt and there was a moment that
stuck with me when you're like trying to
talk to your Egyptian cousin in Egypt
and you're like I want to go see this
place in this place and he just [ __ ]
like puts you in your place in a way
that's like oh [ __ ] that made me think
about my relationship with my cousins in
India yeah like it really does it hits
you in a way that you're like oh [ __ ] I
never looked at myself that way yeah if
you feel like an outsider yeah yeah yeah
and then some of the truths are harsh
yeah yeah is any of the negative
feedback frustrating when like you put
all the time into making something for
you and like the people that look like
you and your experience and then just to
have someone be like you know maybe
someone from like a different Muslim
just sort of like contingent be like hey
you didn't represent this correctly
you're doing this wrong you're
embarrassing all of us yeah I mean we it
sometimes is just disappointing because
it's like you uh yeah you wanna connect
that's why we do this that's why we do
comedies like oh I just want to connect
with people but then you know so
sometimes I'll feel bad about it but
then also sometimes it's so ridiculous
that I can't even pay attention to it
like we had put out pictures just for
season two just pictures and it was like
me and mahershal Ali praying and uh
first comment brother he has too many
prayer beads I was like okay
[Laughter]
brother I'm like oh
that would be a fun one yeah I can't
wait to see what happens you know but
the other thing is because part of part
of this is a reaction to what's been
done to us so for so many decades most
of the content about us is documentaries
right that can be dehumanizing or only
show kind of the worst parts so we're
almost as an audience because we have so
little comedy we're in documentary mode
so people walk into my show and they're
kind of like wait this isn't real and
it's like well yeah it's a comedy it's
like any other comedy but we've been so
conditioned that everything we're
watching about us is like a news report
yeah and so they think I'm making a news
report with jokes and so again I don't
blame the audience I mean I think we're
in a tough spot right yeah just because
you're Muslim you don't necessarily have
their trust like they're skeptical as a
as a yeah because there's been a massive
lack and everything that we've seen and
I think they want to be represented
because the representation is normally
pretty negative yeah I see this a lot
with my parents like they hated Slumdog
Millionaire right like why are you only
showing the bad parts of India and it's
like they're not trying to make a
documentary to your point they're just
making a movie about a kid who had a
horrid life but because there's so many
negative depictions of India we're
starving for something that's showed the
good stuff so that they see this and
like another one another [ __ ] not but
it's also like where Cinema and TV are
at right now right so there was I think
there was an era of like a lot of like
optimistic television yeah you know
something like like a like a Cosby Show
or you know All in the Family like
something that's super positive and you
know Cosby Show more black men started
going to college you know the
statistical facts like statistically
yeah statistical fact yeah in America
yeah right so Will and Grace the same
thing well right level of like after the
film came out like it was some people
say that it advocated for gay marriage
and like it was from Joe Biden said that
yeah Joe Biden right I mean it's so
funny this is so recent and this is
what's really funny about America too
because they look at like other parts of
the world and say oh they're so
backwards and this and that Biden I
think it was not even what 2010 11. said
Will and Grace made him accept gay
people that's why he wants to have gay
marriage exactly that feels like like
that's recent there's pulling data from
like the 90s and it's like 70 of
Americans are against gay marriage and
then Will and Grace comes out and then
by like 2007 eight it's like 30 against
gay marriage yeah but I remember them
being pissed to biting because Obama was
supposed to be supportive first you know
like even Obama was why would why does
Will and Grace make people accept gay
men because you see gay people
three-dimensionally as humans people you
like or as for a lot of us our show was
gay
he hasn't seen it Will and Grace
is about a guy and a girl I mean I
actually have never seen the show and
he's gay and lives with his best friend
he's a girl for a guy and a girl to not
[ __ ] each other right on TV I don't know
about all that no I don't know about
that dude
so Will and Grace was about a gay guy
are you doing a thing I'm not doing a
[ __ ] thing I'm not watching Will and
Grace
you know what I mean what do you think
is going on your elephant says
differently but uh yeah
upset that he's only seen one episode
they keep asking me to watch Seinfeld
you know one of these days that's a
deeply uncultured individual yeah
no but um you were saying
Muslims have a [ __ ] moment white guy
Jesus Christ there's gonna be a gay fat
one yeah what's going on with this guy
dude I'm telling you no it's not yeah
I'm expanding the caliphate bro there's
gonna be a game you know do you know if
you've expanded the caliphate
I don't know I think you have dude I saw
a blonde girl that was Muslim on Tick
Tock why didn't you think it was because
of me
I think you definitely had a part of it
100 yeah blonde Muslim girl on Tick Tock
the blonde musliment really yeah
absolutely damn what I was gonna say
yeah and we're back
what I was gonna say was
um the uh uh oh Cosby right like just uh
that kind of show we haven't had that
and then I think the show that you know
I I did make is so much weirder so it's
this weird thing where it's like Cinema
and TV are at this kind of evolved place
where it's like no one would even make
Cosby now because I think most audiences
are like we already saw that we want
something a little bit different yeah it
doesn't feel as grounded we're kind of
in a more grounded satirical place just
in terms of television and Cinema but
then yeah then you have groups who just
haven't had a show that's even just like
quote unquote normal so again like I
kind of feel for that I feel for the
when the audience doesn't like what I'm
doing because I'm like I get it you do
want the Cosby moment but the Cosby
moment was 40 years ago 30 years ago and
so it's weird because we're just it's
this this time Gap yeah go go out no I'm
saying it's always going to be people in
your culture who are the most critical
right yeah yeah that's like think about
like the powers or the empires like it
was black people complaining the most
about those shows yeah and like us so
inauthentic too it's personal yeah yeah
it's personal but the conversation is
all good in a way even if people are
disagreeing because that's kind of the
whole point because if it's touching on
a nerve then people are talking about
something and the whole point is for a
show to create conversation how long did
it take you to get to that place
emotionally even if it's negative at
least they're talking yeah after the
second season I got to that place okay
yeah how many takes of that guy clean
your feet did you have to do
um a lot really yeah it was in the pilot
weird when you had to go in between
because that [ __ ] was super what
happened to me at a mosque get out of
here yeah this guy you know was trying
to show me how to how to do the cleaning
for the prayer so he he grabbed my foot
and
and he was webbing to weapon he webbed
he went I was webbed and and and it
happened and I wrote about it and I'm
here and I'm okay oh nice yeah I mean
that's fire do you still talk to that
guy I didn't know him yeah no I don't
I've never seen him again no eye contact
nothing just I didn't like get webbed
and then asked for his number like no it
was just it ended there he was uh as a
Catholic I've had similar experiences
but it looks like a web when it comes
out